[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and myers-drysdale the
phoenix sun's vice president and the
phoenix suns color analyst for fox
sports
arizona annie good to talk to you this
morning if i would have said to you back
in say november the phoenix suns are
going to be playing in the western
conference finals what would you have
said
well being in the organization for 14
years now i would have said yes because
of the way they ended in the
in the bubble last year and then uh
certainly with uh
you know monty's really done an
incredible job in his staff
uh as far as getting these guys to
believe in
his system in the team and uh as one for
all
also we we saw them i think people
might have looked at them as like a cute
team in the bubble when they went 8-0
and a good story and then we weren't
sure if it would carry over
but then getting chris paul like what
did you see different
with chris paul on that team that maybe
was lacking
yeah and certainly chris is unbelievable
as far as his leadership and his
relationship with monty and willie green
and uh you know
having jake crowder was huge uh
certainly the guards we brought in but
um just the maturation of of ayton
d'andre and uh mikhail bridges and and
certainly cam johnson
is it's almost like we are peaking for
the the
uh playoffs there's no question about it
um we have the second best record in the
league
and it was interesting going into the
playoffs that people didn't pick us at
all
i mean we're still the underdog even
against the clippers
chris paul's status for game two is what
uh we don't know yet we haven't been
told and um
it's just uh day to day but you know
just having him on the court in his
presence
uh his ability to communicate with the
other players
i think it's such a big plus and uh he's
always in their ear and and everybody
you know we've talked about it all
season long whether eddie johnson or
kevin ray and myself and uh
you know when we we've had the chance to
talk to monty and some of the players
and
you know chris is in their ear on the
floor on the bench
you know it just uh in the locker room
constantly talking to them and
you know book has said it too is nobody
gets upset at each other no matter how
much you know there may be
some kind of you know aggressive talk to
each other
but it's all in good faith and uh all
about the team getting better and uh
you know chris has brought that
leadership and monty continues to talk
about it
for those who haven't seen devin booker
how would you describe his game
well book he is uh coming into
phoenix and we had a lot of guards at
that time and
a lot left and he was a rookie that had
sat the bench at kentucky
and came in and pj tucker was there at
the time and
and i think that really helped his game
also just every
a lot of different people that have come
in he had what six different coaches
so uh the ability to be able to learn
under a lot of different people and and
sustain his positiveness but i know that
kobe was a great influence on him his
father has been a great influence on him
but uh he if you look for you know dane
has got an unbelievable game
you know steph's got an unbelievable
game uh you go down the list but
right now book is probably the most like
kobe in the way that he plays the game
and uh certainly his mid-range game is
as
you know as good as good as uh chris
paul's
um but uh his ability to shoot the three
and um handle the ball
and you know he really wants to be
recognized for his defense too his
defense has gotten better but
you know he's got a chip on his shoulder
in the sense that
hasn't been picked for the all-star
games he's been uh alternate
and certainly has not made any of the
teams whether it be defensive or
all nba and uh that sticks with you and
it drives you but
i think his game is most like kobe's but
i also think it's most like
devin bookers yeah i was wondering about
that the kobe comparison because it's a
little tricky because kobe had this
attack mode constantly like he wanted to
kill you
and and booker i don't know if he has
that temperament that he wants to
continue to bring it yeah but if you if
you
they were pretty close and they talked a
lot and
i think uh you know no not too many
people have what kobe had i think
russ westbrook probably has that the
most in the game right now
uh for me that i that i watch and uh
but you know devin shows it in a
different way
and he is he's got a lot of killer
instinct but it shows a different way
and uh you know nobody's cold nobody's
michael nobody's lebron
and uh but certainly i think that devin
booker has established himself
uh but but again you know a lot of
people talk about uh
donovan mitchell they're talking about
mitchell more than in utah than they are
about book and
in phoenix but uh you know booker's just
he's just taking his time and i think
people will see
i mean what he did yesterday the triple
double
and uh you know he's been a tough
rebounding guard he
rebounds what seven rebounds a game and
he can get four to
six assists a game but last night he got
11. so uh
you know he's capable and we've seen him
what you know against boston he had 70
points so
we know that he can score and but when
he's not scoring he can do other things
and i think that that's the one thing
that
he prides himself on uh as kobe did you
know there's games where it just
doesn't work for you but certainly i
think that uh you know
playing defense setting screens blocking
out
and he's recognizing that more and more
anne myers drysdale the
hall of famer phoenix sons vice
president sons color analyst for fox
sports arizona how well did you know
kobe
um you know well you know his dad
coached the la sparks
and uh so that's where i really first
got to know kobe
and uh certainly he lives down in orange
county where i'm in
and uh we've had interaction and so
forth and probably not as close and what
i love is a lot of the wnba players like
a jewel lloyd and
uh sabrina nesco and diana diana
trosten's been given the white mamba
name by kobe and uh certainly bruin grew
up
in southern california idolizing him and
uh so you know he's been around the
the wnba quite a bit and that was kind
of a big loss for that side and as a
matter of fact
yesterday's game the new york liberty at
los angeles parks was the day of the
25th anniversary
of the wnba starting and
what's unfortunate that it didn't get a
lot of coverage it was tough because
you're going against
not only the the two games but also the
us open
but um you know he because he was so
involved with women's basketball
and uh his camps um you know i got to
know him through there and would see him
at a lot of different games
we've been talking a lot about ben
simmons today and i'm guessing with your
title as
son's vice president you can't talk
about somebody individually i don't know
i don't want to get you in trouble but
um you know that this mental hurdle
that we have it's not necessa it's
physical but then it becomes
mental like i don't know any when when
when athletes have to think that's
usually when they get in trouble they
usually react here
and i don't know like ben simmons is not
a quick fix where you just go hey work
on your form
it's mental now well
i'm not going to say anything on that
but i you know my late husband don
brysville used to say don't think it
hurts the ball club
and uh so you know you just go out there
and play
um i remember magic when he played for
the los angeles lakers and uh he was
limited he was very young when he came
in with the
the lakers but he was limited in a lot
of things that he
could do and couldn't do but the one
thing that magic did is
every summer he worked on what he
couldn't do
and he improved on that uh whether it be
his outsized shot or his defense and so
forth but
uh you know the players that want to get
better and want to be great
work on the things that they're not
quite as efficient on
when you went to the pacers camp who who
were the players
with the pacers uh johnny davis
who i had known with the pan am games
and uh
we had george mcginnis and alex english
uh brad davis uh
you know it's a free agent rookie camp
so i was signed as a free agent i wasn't
drafted
and um trying you know i mean it's been
a long time dan
i know a long time but but but for those
of us
in the audience who don't know explain
you came out of ucla
and you were like this was a big deal
you were invited to
camp were you treated as just a
basketball player when you got there
well there were a lot of things that had
happened to to you know i guess prepare
me for that whether
my whole life playing sports and in the
game of basketball
and uh playing usa basketball and
playing against the men growing up and
playing at poly pavilion and pick up
games but
certainly my brother david playing for
coach john wooden winning a couple of
national championships and
he was the number one draft pick for the
lakers and was in the trade that brought
kareem to la and
so david was playing in milwaukee uh
when i went to ucla it was a human
interest story so the media talked a lot
about my brother david and myself
i went to the olympics we won silver it
was the first time they had women's
basketball in the olympics
my senior year we won the national
championship so i mean being in los
angeles being at ucla
i had received a lot of exposure and uh
i was planning to go to the 1980
olympics as
you still had to be amateur at that time
so the new owner of the indiana pacers
was sam nassey
i got a call when i came back from
russia in the spartacade games and
certainly david being in the nba i knew
a lot of people in the nba
players and and coaches being on all
these inter different international
teams
so it's not like people didn't know who
i was
um it's certainly a thing where
you know i was just as surprised as
anybody else but i thought it was an
opportunity of a lifetime
that a lot of people don't get asked for
something like that and
i had a lot of belief in my ability uh
whether a lot of people thought it was a
publicity stunt
um i know that there were but at that
time i didn't think that
i thought it was uh somebody was giving
me a chance to do something
and and i took it and so mentally
physically emotionally it was the best i
was ever prepared to play the game
i mean i focused on on working out with
my one of my other brothers and
uh you know mentally he got in my head
and physically i was talking to david
and talking to other people
um so you know i was ready but uh it was
a different situation did they
treat me you know uh slick leonard who
was the coach
came out several times to california to
talk me out of it
uh he did not want this to happen jack
mccloskey
well i i think he just grew up in a
different generation i mean this was we
didn't really have some girl tryout in
the nba
uh that certainly was uh the attitude of
a lot of the media
and uh but um and i never known
uh dan what a press conference was i
just you know
one i wasn't very good at talking but a
press conference what was that
uh so we had a press conference and um
certainly i've been
interviewed a lot when i was at ucla and
even before that
in high school in elementary school but
um now this press conference was pretty
uh attacking by the media and i was very
caught off guard on that
so i didn't know how to deal with that
very well but i got to indiana
and uh you know it was going to happen i
mean the the owner was
going to have it happen and i agreed to
do it so jack mccloskey was one of the
assistants and he said
you know one point fundamentally i was
better than half the guys out there
so that's from my ucla days certainly
and knowing the fundamentals
but um you know it's a great experience
for me i mean we had uh
the three days of two day practices and
i know it was tough on the guys because
it was a no-win situation for them
um you know if they block my shot no big
deal it's only a girl
but if i made a shot ah you let some
girl beat you which is the name of my
book
you let some girl beat you come on pat
you you know
or dan you and i give if we played and
if i beat you
what do you think the danettes would say
you wouldn't beat me oh
you would not be well but see that's
your attitude
well you know you went to dayton no but
it wouldn't
it wouldn't matter who i was talking to
i would say they wouldn't beat me
i know that's who you are yes that's
what i love about you
yes and you have to have that attitude
and that's what i had
going into play against the guys because
i'd always played against the guys
so even though a lot of people felt well
she can't do this and she can't do that
and she can't do that
and i always thought what can i do you
know and even now when i when i was the
general manager for the phoenix mercury
and even when i looked at the nba i look
at what guys
can do not you know there's a deficiency
in everybody's game
but look at why did you pick that person
well you picked them for a certain
reason
so i i want to see what they can do and
certainly as far as
you know mentally as you mentioned
earlier you know it's a lot of
you've got to be in a good frame of mind
and you have to have a lot of positive
people around you
and so with my tryout i did have
positive people around me
and thank goodness i didn't have social
media then
how close are we to uh a female head
coach in the nba
i think it's going to happen there's no
question the fact that we're talking
about it and it's been exposed
out there so much it's like you know
charles was talking last night about
you know the the black coaches you've
got to have the conversations you've got
to bring the
issues out so people are aware of them
and whether you agree or disagree
you have to have i think the
conversation to be able to talk about it
and the fact that we've talked about
having a woman coach in the nba um
it's going to happen and now who that
organization is going to be who that
general manager and owner is going to be
positive about it
then you got to sell your media your
local market uh because the media is not
for it um you know and that's very
obvious
but uh it's going to be somebody that's
got to be a strong personality that's
been in the game
and has had things said about them
already and uh
certainly we know that becky hammond is
out there and uh people have talked
about dawn staley at south carolina but
you know this was talk when pat summitt
and tara vanderveer
there was talk about them taking over as
coaches on the men's side so
you know it's not like this is new uh
it's been going on for a long time
it's great to talk to you as always and
uh so good to see you
and and how is your jumper when's the
last time you took a shot
well i got a basket in the backyard so
i'll shoot my little three bankers
okay and that drives me nuts the bank
shot
almost disappeared that was bank shot
well that was one of coach wooden he
loved the bank shot
uh tim duncan it's been proven it's a
higher percentage of the shot going in
and if it's missed
70 percent of the shots are dropped
within that area so you give an
opportunity to your teammate
to get a rebound but i don't miss so
they don't have to worry about a rebound
and
you know that you know that is that what
reggie says
uh i don't i don't mess with reggie when
it comes to a shooting contest i don't
mess with reggie
i know my limitations annie uh hey
thanks for joining us and uh
good luck the rest of the series hey
thanks and watch the mercury too
that's ann myers drysdale the phoenix
suns vice president and uh color analyst
for fox sports
arizona